hey Gary I have a question for you for
askgaryvee who cares about that question
Gary this is more important question how
are you if you were the owner of the New
York Jets gonna turn around this team
and make us a Super Bowl contender
because we both know that's all that
matters and he's a Giants fan who who
gives a [ __ ] what he has to say good
Giants thanks Brad and scooter for the
question you know I mean the true answer
to the question because I loved you know
we decided to go straight on this show
the true answer is I'd go in and on it
that's what I do so as close as I am
working with the Jets as a client
watching every play staying on top of it
there's still nuances that are just not
you know known to me you know I think
one thing I would do for example if I
bought the Jets today I would mandate
from the top and this would probably
make it a little harder to get a GM and
so that's something I'd have to quantify
but I would mandate that we draft a
quarterback every two years in the first
two rounds of the NFL Draft until we had
our guy right so like I think it's a
quarterback league the rules go in that
way and you have the reverse engineer of
the league and so for example right now
I would draft the quarterback in round
one or two this year because though I've
given you know the benefit of doubt he's
clearly not the overwhelming this is
Andrew Luck sitting in our pocket so we
have to draft another quarterback and if
it's not politically correct to Gino and
his agents or to the New York media or
the fan base I wouldn't care because I
would dictate to victory and I think
that's the right strategy right now in
the NFL if you do not have a quarterback
first two rounds you draft one you bring
them in if you don't feel good about I
give it I give it 24 months but after
full 24 months after the second season
of that player by the way whether he
played a snap or not I would draft
another one and another one and another
one until I had one because that is the
linchpin I'd also work on the PR team I
would do a weekly show livestream show
with the fan base so they could pound me
with all their angers and I pound them
back because that's the kind of owner
I'd be I would do a bunch of marketing
things you've heard me in the past I'd
send a jersey of a Jets jersey to every
six-year-old in the tri-state area
on their sixth birthday
I would probably do a ton of
inappropriate things at this point
there's you know like get into it with
the media because I think they're out of
their mind with the way they're handling
jets in this giant city
I would like watch the game from the
stands which I think would be an
interesting new thing but that would be
tough because I curse that opponents and
the NFL would try to reel me in so those
are some of the things I'd be doing oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe